and joining us now on the rich eisen
show is the winner of this week's
toughest player on planet earth from
gorilla glue and he gets the nil deal a
check and he gets a get some product
ladies and gentlemen sincere mccormack
let's go
running back how are you sincere
i'm doing great today i just got done
with football practice and uh just
looking forward to the rest of my day
okay let's get to it so um how did you
find your way to utsa to
you uh texas san antonio sincere your
path uh it's kind of a kind of a journey
i was born and raised in california my
mom decided to
move to vegas and then come on there she
met someone and we ended up moving to
texas i was starting to meet a lot more
people
um gradually met this guy named um chris
pryor he went to jetson and then from on
there my journey kind of just set off i
was kind of just making a name for
myself coming into a new city um you
know meeting frank wilson frank wilson
was the first offer i had at utsa and
talking to him knowing the process of
what i could you know what could be done
here and i was i took a chance on myself
and i bet on myself every single time so
i knew you know coming to utsa that you
know i can make a change make something
happen here and that's what that's what
that's what we're doing right now i'll
be honest with you sincere i'll be
sincere um we have been we have been
checking you out since we started this
nil deal uh toughest player on planet
earth i mean you popped off the screen
with 100 yard performances in three of
your first four games and now here you
are part of the 15th ranked road runners
team and one of only four
undefeated teams remaining in big time
college football um how is this landing
on you and your teammates that you're
performing so well it's um you know
everybody in the um in the locker room
and um even outside like in the
community you're just you know happy and
excited but it's the culture that was
instilling to us you know thinking uh
coach traylor um bringing that culture
in and having older guys live up to that
culture and just you know
just the details and everything we
we put in it um during the summer um
leading up into the fall um you know and
and financing our results come and you
know come to truth uh come come to you
know uh reality so that's something that
you know we we pride ourselves in and
you know just seeing it develop is
something that we're we're excited for
and we're happy for all right i mean so
you've got you're ranked seventh
currently in an fbs uh rushing yards
list right now with a thousand sixty
you've got 17 career hundred yard
rushing games also a school record
you hold the school records for career
rushing yards and rushing touchdowns uh
what's your goal when it all comes down
to sincere mccormick what do you got for
me um
you know it what it comes down to is to
you know do everything i can
for you know to lead hopefully get up to
the top three a lot of times it's all
said and done um score as many
touchdowns as i can probably get to 15
but really all i think about is just
winning the games with my teammates and
i let everything fall into play because
i know i'm gonna get married but
for my team just doing everything i can
um just being a team player you know
i'm excited i get i achieved all my
goals achieve the goals that you know
came by but you can't really pay
attention to that because you know you
get you stay away from the disenjoy in
the moment and you know season the
moment with your teammates so you know
just letting that you know
uh
develop itself i just don't really worry
about that all right it's it's uh the
four remaining undefeated teams i just
mentioned moments ago in the fbs georgia
cincinnati oklahoma and utsa
do you want a piece of these guys
sincere mccormick you want a piece of
these guys you're ranked 23rd your
team's ranked 23rd in the college
football playoff rankings right now
of course of course i want a piece of
them you know just to showcase our
talent that we have here at ucsa i know
we're a new program but we're capable a
lot a lot more than what people think um
you know the competition level really
don't matter you know because we all
have to suit up the same wake up the
same go through the same thing so you
know just be able to showcase our talent
and get those opponents will be you know
uh something big for this program okay
and then the most important job that you
have which is one of the many reasons
why you're getting this
award is your most important job you're
a dad correct sincere yes yes sir my dad
my uh my daughter came here monday i've
been spending time with her ever since
she started walking around and you know
how little girls get they start she's
about to be one tomorrow
um so you know she started getting into
a lot of things so you know as a dad you
gotta say no no no many times so they
don't touch anything but you know i'm
happy that she she came down okay
your one door one-year-old daughter
legacy so now i know for sure
because i've been asking everybody who's
winning the toughest player on planet
earth award from girl gorilla glue the
nil deal to check for a thousand dollars
that obviously is going to come in handy
but you must have some stuff of legacies
that requires fixing there has to be
some toy something that the glue
or tape will come in handy with
incorrect sincere yeah an exciting thing
would just happened uh with the blue um
always fixing her her little car that
she has and one of the pieces fell off
so definitely uh we don't need that
gorilla glue um to stick it back on i
know it's one of the toughest glue out
there so i must definitely need it
yes yes it is the toughest it for the
toughest jobs and clearly that's the
most important job that you've got going
on right there i'm loving this sincere
mccormick i'm rooting for you and your
team um let's have a little bit of fun
though going out the door right
that there's a ut sa but there's you
know taxes and uh
which team is better
in the ut football system sincere
mccormack
well you know 2022 will showcase that um
but you know can't speak ahead but you
know like i said i'm betting on myself
i'm better than my team all day okay so
you know you're too classy to go horns
down is basically what you're saying
right now sincere mccormick yeah i was
too classy i like to keep it classy
that's why you're getting this award hey
uh congratulations to you uh and your
team uh with what you've done so far you
know enjoyed the time with your daughter
and um i'm just uh i'm excited for you
is the plan to play on sundays one day
for you sincere is that the plan of
course um that's something that me and
my family you know we uh you know
look at at times but you know uh making
sure getting that education first though
so you know you can't can't uh believe
here without the education so you know
that's the first thing my mom you know
um instilled in to me um she wants me to
get my education first but you know
playing on sundays uh that i'm i'm
looking forward to doing that as well so
um anything i end up you know i'll be
grateful for it well i look forward to
meeting you one day in that regard uh if
not before at the combine and i'll know
who you are not only because of this but
when we shake hands
my hand will stick to yours because
it'll have gorilla glue all over it so
i'll know i know that you know i look
forward to that sincere
don't get stuck on the ground on that
40. okay
you know
that's my problem is gravity sincere
mccormick you're right that is my
problem from the very beginning it's
been gravity so you know i'll look at
your fit your tape and you'll teach me
something on that front hey rich i see
here on on sincerest twitter that uh
meet meet nation is selling run 3mc
t-shirts is this free this is your shirt
sincere
yes sir uh run 3mc search is uh came out
last year before the nil
and then when the nil came out
we started proceeding to have the run 3m
t-shirt so hopefully everybody get a
chance to get them um they're on my way
they're on my uh twitter page um they're
my bio on my instagram so you can just
click the link and buy a sweater or a
shirt well i just bought a t-shirt hey
there's another cell yeah so we got yeah
we'll have we'll have it here on the
show at some point okay this is great
this is what a day
enjoy your enjoy your daughter's
birthday sincere congrats on all of
thank you
sincere mccormick university of texas at
san antonio running back and the winner
of this week's
gorilla glue toughest player on planet
earth
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here